the coronavirus outbreak
hit people across the world claiming too
many lives
it infected the very roots of our
economy and raised many questions about
our health care systems
in this first episode of what's left we
take a closer look
at the spread of the crisis to the
economy
this crisis might just be the
opportunity to rethink europe's current
economic model
and here's how
[Music]
as countries start deconfining one after
the other
economic figures are out and they're not
reassuring
the global freeze of the economy a first
in modern history
is said to cause the eurozone to
contract by 7.5 percent this year
the worst recession since the great
depression
[Music]
the jobs of up to 59 million people in
europe are at risk
that's almost the entire population of
france
beyond the numbers we are talking about
the livelihoods of citizens
their incomes and their plans for the
future that were put in question
overnight
there are legislative and budgetary
actions by member states since the
beginning of the crisis
however these measures will affect
unevenly member states
due to the different spread of the virus
but also to the different structure of
the economy
of those states it took a month of
confinement before eu leaders finally
took
action as one united bloc a common
bazooka package
amounting to 540 billion euros was
agreed on in april to protect workers
businesses
and countries
[Music]
in the longer term all eu countries will
need cash to face the economy
consequences of the crisis
in other words finance a massive
recovery plan
if we take a look at history we may find
some clues to figure out what to do next
in the 1930s to pull his country out of
the depression
roosevelt decided to take radical
measures
he tripled the federal budget in a few
years creating new resources putting in
place of federal
tax on profits and on the richest the
first year it didn't work out
roosevelt emitted bonds for a few years
and with a massive stimulus package his
tax plan paid off
for today's progressives this precedent
in history could give us a way out
one tool governments have in their
toolbox to finance their actions in
addition to taxation
is debt in normal times all european
countries can issue bonds to borrow
money on the financial markets
but at some point those countries will
have to reimburse the money
if financial markets trust your country
they will lend money easily
at low interest rates
but for other countries that don't look
quite as stable interest rates can rise
has a tremendous impact on the country's
ability to restore its economic strength
what might seem like a pretty
insignificant rise in interest rates
can quite quickly turn into billions of
euros to be paid back
sk control notification
in order to avoid this competition
between states and make sure
we have a truly solidarity-based
recovery progressives in the european
parliament
but the idea of issuing corona bonds at
the european level on the table
in other words a common european debt
jacques
[Music]
if the eu jointly borrows money on the
financial markets
it also needs to be able to jointly pay
back money borrowed
the progressives are pushing to create
new owned resources for the eu budget
to create independent revenue for the eu
asking for a fee on unrecycled plastics
drawing resources from the european
emissions trade system
raising income taxes on big corporates
creating a digital services tax
putting in place a tax on financial
transactions while making sure the
revenues from tax avoidance and tax
evasion go where the money is needed
[Music]
a few weeks into confinement people woke
up to a world
where the air was clean and where
traffic wasn't a nuisance anymore
spectacular drops in co2 emissions were
observed
but this doesn't give us the bigger
picture
in the last year co2 emissions have
risen more rapidly than in the 60s and
70s
from 0.8 units to 2.8 per year
temperatures continue to rise everywhere
and with it our need
to deal with the situation
[Music]
so how do we do it how do we protect
citizens jobs and livelihoods
while addressing the biggest challenge
humanity has probably
ever had to face for the socialists and
democrats
the path is clear it's called the green
new deal
with a just transition at its heart to
ensure that
no one is left behind when we rebuild
our academies
and our societies on a sustainable basis
in the end progressive ideas caught the
commission's ear and by the end of
may it proposed a comprehensive recovery
plan 750 billion euros to support the
blocks economies
these investments would come on top of
an existing 1.1 trillion euro wide
budgetary plan
the hardest hit sectors in the most
affected regions must be provided with a
lifeline
to ensure they don't have to fight
workers or close down before recovery
kicks in
the snd group will continue putting
pressure on eu leaders
so that europe can live up to its
ambitions
european with the coronavirus crisis
we've all been left in a state of shock
first and foremost
was protecting people's health
supporting the most vulnerable in
society
and ensuring that workers will have a
job to return
to after the end of the outbreak but
then we also woke up to a new world of
possibilities
working from home experimenting new
forms of solidarity
and when the clapping stops and when bit
by bit that sense of normality
comes back into our lives what will we
do
will we go back to our old ways or will
we embrace
real change in this crisis the
progressives will have fought and pushed
for real change
refusing to sit on the sidewalk of
history while watching workers
businesses and our planet go bust now it
is time to be bold and innovative and
build a better future for all
stay tuned for next episode of what's
left where we will explore in more depth
how tomorrow's world could look like